foreign
people welcome to honest trailer
commentaries uh what are we talking
about today pregnancy Sonic
um and only pregnancy nothing wrong we
all get curious about look it up on Tick
Tock but we're unfortunately we're
talking about uh Transformers oh I wish
it was yeah we'll be giving more
thoughts about the film to the degree to
which we have them
um my laptop's about to die so let's
make this a quick one well we'll try to
get it in before the battery goes out
yeah or I'll just skip the part where
you ask questions and we can I think we
can zip through this we'll see we'll see
yeah we are going to do you want to do
questions first there's no suspense yes
Transformers movie yeah uh well we'll
get into it yeah we'll talk about the
movie we've got some deleted scenes
we'll do a q a and then we'll teach you
with next week's even worse movie and
then I gotta tells a bunch of beasts who
do not have wheels to roll out that's
about where this movie's at it's like no
you're you're a bird you don't roll out
well he could tell them to max out right
because they're maximals yeah that would
have been better I like that better I
like that to the max come on yeah uh and
that's again Max the one to watch for
HBO
[Laughter]
max out
it was probably yells promos for
a 10 year old HBO program the idol max
out John from Cincinnati max out
um
oh what's the one where okay we'll get
it we'll get into that later uh all
right so yeah this this move is a huge
disappointment um I think it is it's
very Transformers I'm coming to realize
is my least favorite franchise um
because I've done so many of them and
they what the worst thing was giving me
hope with bumblebee right that was the
worst thing they could have done yeah I
think that's what stings about this one
because it's it's not like the worst
thing in the world it's just bumblebee
really did try it in addition to the
Transformer story there is this kind of
like sweet Coming of Age human story
that is kind of heartfelt and they do
give it some time and attention and then
this one we're right back to the humans
are just there to like grab the
MacGuffin and now all the dialogue is
like no get it come here run run you
know like there's nobody says anything
that's more than three line three
letters both of the humans could have
been replaced by Transformers they could
have been Brooklyn bought one one hit
what basically is by the end uh but yeah
like that I think that's what's at this
point he's like if we we're not gonna
get baehem
okay yeah it looks it doesn't look as
confusing but it doesn't look any better
it just it's the same kind of CGI sludge
and the but it's comprehensible yeah
after going back and re-watching Bay
forbers like it's ugly and it's weird
and it's chaotic and a lot of the time
it doesn't look like anything but he is
he is really trying for like this big
cinematic epic huge scale finale a lot
of camera movement there's a lot of like
oh it's a real thing in the foreground
but a transformer in the background and
you're he's trying right you're going to
see a lot of chaos you're going to see a
lot of nonsense but you are going to see
some cool imagery and some crazy stuff
model that he met at a Victoria's Secret
shoot is in the foreground going whoa
yeah
medical Bay is right there yeah then he
pins up there to show you bumblebee
there it's not as good as like ambulance
but there is there is bayhem to be had
and it's like okay if you're not gonna
do that then I would like the the
Bumblebee like at least then tell me a
real story and make it like a real movie
this one it kind of feels like we're
doing if it's not neither yeah it's not
the actions like mid and not that
exciting oh the obligatory Universe
building that they drop onto the end of
it is an Alzheimer this is a dark
Universe this is this is the Hasbro
version of the dark yeah this is 100
welcome to my lab here's the creature
I'm just gonna jump ahead we'll spoil it
okay it's a very let's go
all right laptop style let's go
[Music]
fighting smacks out that was good I like
seeking The Matrix of leadership the
all-spark the sun Harvester with the
Matrix of leadership again the space
Bridge the seed
taxi cab confessions inside a
Transformer yeah now I'm in yeah I'd Max
that out dream on roll out
but nothing can prepare you for where
their desperate search for the key will
take them this time it's Earth it's
always early eat Earth it's always Earth
there are no planets besides Earth and
Cybertron you fool you absolute buffoon
Transformers rise of the beasts after
Michael Bay made you feel insane for 10
long years
and Bumblebee made you feel hope again
get ready to feel Nostalgia for a time
before live-action Transformers movies
because when a generic new Sky beam
thingy is discovered we don't really
dive into it in this one but hey this is
super
remember the 90s 90s and I'm not as
familiar with the exact chronology of
the 80s so for bumblebee I was like okay
these are all popular 80 songs but they
get they drop Biggie's hypnotized
because like up until then they're doing
okay it's every like if you liked
backpack rap in the early 90s it's like
every it's like you get a day La Soul
shout out and then check the rhyme it's
like having all the words to skilos yeah
it's like every one of those songs
exactly what you'd expect and find but
then yeah there's this random shot
they're driving across I think it's like
a Brooklyn Bridge into Manhattan and you
just that you come up with like the most
in the most recognizable intro that
sounds the most like like influence all
the early 2000s it's completely the
wrong era it's just like how did they
like why like if you're gonna put in the
time and the effort to put all these
other classic songs that are from the
right era why ruin it with this one
completely wrong needle drop that feels
out of place I'm sure it wasn't the only
thing oh we get into it in the tag it's
not the only thing they should but uh
very weird because it doesn't sound like
1994 or earlier style of rap at all it
doesn't recall that era like they're
trying to and that they are very
specifically crawling because there's
even a bit uh Dominique Fishback Elena I
think it's her character she like her
bit is that she sings to herself when
she gets nervous and they even use era
appropriate songs there like she said
TLC's Waterfalls which was a 1993 or 90
percent they should have gotten um snow
to do Transformer yeah a remix
what a shame but anyway yeah it is it's
a really weird Choice it'd be like if in
bumblebee they were like and now
um spacehog
what's a good
um yeah
anyways that's that's how dare you how
dare you okay keep going
because I mean can you believe it the
evil tarot cards will come to get their
precious key get the key well the
Autobots fight to keep the key to
preserve the key no matter the cost
protect the keys
do we have the key the key but sometimes
the reverse happens
but friends wolf keys to visit young
worlds if you give us this key if
tomorrow I will light the beacon oh
don't worry the rest of the story is
told with the same delicate subtlety so
yellow robots that transform into cars
even though you're from way out in space
but now there's this key that opens a
portal back to your home and when you
know this because there's a Beacon Light
in the sky that I can't see because I'm
human everybody got that you're saying
this thing Unicron eats planets to
survive yes wigglier all right so you're
a maximal y'all are out of the box what
was those things that attacked us
earlier terracons
this is like if every character was
poochie and like they came from outer
space and when they're off camera people
should be asking so you're poochie from
outer space and you came from a
different place and now you're here the
maximals are so proactive yeah I like
that Anthony Ramos because it's it's
almost like his dialogue from Hamilton
where he's kind of like tell him what
your name is it's like that again like
he's just like he's he's just like the
hype man I should have done it if I
would be very curious to go back through
it or to get the script and just search
for so what you're saying is like just
restating the exposition just for our
benefits yeah well right because it get
us to the next monkey punch it
definitely feels like there were some
studio notes where they were like they
were concerned that this plot is too
confusing for kids I don't think it is
but I feel like there must have been
some a meeting about that because we do
have five or six lines of dialogue where
it's just like randomly restating what
we already know in case kids got lost
and I love how the character
introductions are usually character
enters says I am my name it's like that
South Park that they made with AI where
everybody just like takes a step forward
it's their line
like ah like maybe this was already
written by AI if any movie I've seen
this year was actually already written
sneakily by Ai and they didn't tell us
it was this I think it was this one I
think there was a there was a Polish
past done by Alan chat GPT yeah hey I'm
the bird I'm Michelle yo okay all right
I'm done
on one side of the screen and play all
the monkey punching on the other deal
yeah
meet Noah he's Miles Morales that's it
that's the character
the mom is the same yes yeah it's
actually it's actually Miles Morales so
I should have put that in but anyways
keep going
did older brother from Brooklyn
[Music]
Avenue Brooklyn New York Elena is a
brilliant Museum intern from Brooklyn
Brooklyn all right New York all day he
represents Brooklyn while she was raised
down in Brookwood I'm from Bushwick I'm
never leaving Brooklyn again Brooklyn
baby yes Brooklyn I was raised out in
Brooklyn Elena is armed with knowledge
about literally every field from
paleontology that's a good one but the
Ankylosaurus also armor dinosaur to all
of art history that's eventually
sketches legit oh my God send his Greek
curse tablet it would be expensive but
it's a fake I think it might be Aztec or
Inca to masonry that stonework is 17th
century two hieroglyphics this symbol is
definitely not hieroglyphic to the
geographical layout of Cusco Peru
somehow that's Santo Domingo the Spanish
builted on top of an old Inca Temple and
it's my first time
I've liked Dominique Fishback in pretty
much every other thing I've ever seen
her inches yes
[Music]
it's warm this year was that uh David uh
the wire guy made that with Oscar Isaac
made like uh oh uh uh yeah show me here
show me a here yeah I was like wow she's
one to watch I mean catch that cash that
check but
bad
there's nothing she could do it's not a
character she's literally like Robert
Langdon wherever where they go she's
just like oh they're two pyramids uh
like what who cares like you don't need
to put all the nobody's watching a
Transformers movie for the puzzles right
and I didn't understand why we spent so
much time on that stuff like it thought
it was Uncharted or something and it's
like and they spent so much time with
Noah and the little brother and if she's
just there to spout out fun facts like
she could be a Transformer she could
voice a Transformer or just make Noah
he's like a fire fired paleontologist or
something and he can he can know things
there was nothing there were there were
zero there was half a human character
split between two humans they need a
those two needed like a bit you know
like their bit was they're both from
Brooklyn right but that's not a bit like
they know from Brooke from New York New
York City East New York uh yeah like I
don't I like they needed a game you know
like an improv like they needed like a
premise like they needed like what is
their relationship and why are they on
this adventure together and like what is
their whole deal there's nothing she had
to get this bowl of pasta to the
president yeah it's just like they're
just there like there's a scene
literally where the Transformers are
like you guys want to come yeah and
they're like wow all right yeah I guess
it's our planet and it's like no no
okay
that's like that's really like not how
stories that's a better way you gotta
they gotta have feel compelled they need
to go on that Adventure
all right keep going hang on is she
carbon dating now she's an intern
dialogue that says she's an internship
Davidson he's more desperate for human
approval than those Dolphins they train
to predict the Super Bowl
there you go now we're friends but what
about for friendship in a character that
aimed for a combination of Bugs Bunny
and a mask but while he may not be funny
he is smoking
I love this part make sure you melt the
voice box real good I don't want him
coming back again
watch the evil Planet eating Unicron
never sacrifice with Kanye well he
outsources his villainy to the evil
Scourge who will Outsource his ability
to a sad pack of dogs kill the other
humans
I thought online they're referring to
those little guys as scorpions I think
they're like those are supposed to be
transforming scorpions they look I agree
with you dogs I thought I thought like
they were supposed to be like yeah they
read to me as attack dogs and it was
like a lot of bureaucracy in the yeah
but they're they're literally called
like scorpions or something like they're
supposed to be bug-like I guess
I have no sense of what the stakes were
the key can stop Unicron the key oh no
it's the it is the exact costume I
already regret asking it's the cosmic
for Masters of the Universe it's the
exact same
key the grill door yeah it opens portals
to anywhere in space time okay so the
idea it lost transformatron so they need
to get back to Cybertron I don't care so
the idea is if Unicron had the key he
could just portal to any planet in the
universe and eat it okay whereas
otherwise he has to like slowly float
slowly float there the the long way and
uh it takes forever and he could starve
before he reaches the next world he
wants to devour no seriously they have
Coleman Domingo do a lot of dialogue I
was like I'm starving so they have to
lay out snacks for him to get from one
planet to the next you you're saying
that in a humorous tone of voice that is
exactly the plot of this movie it's a
Scourge uh Peter Dinklage Scourge has to
fly around the universe and like fine
worlds that are close enough for Unicron
to devour before he wastes away or like
like guys of dies of uh starvation he's
like like Ezra Miller's uh snack guy
yeah exactly and and so that's why they
want the trans word because then they
could just then they could just pass
travel right around the and that's why
it's also you gotta save Earth and
because he could eat Earth and then he
could portal right to Cybertron and eat
Cybertron of course he could yeah all
right but that's also why well there you
go but that's also why Optimus Prime and
the Autobots want the transworth because
then they could bring themselves back to
Cybertron they have no way of getting
home they're stranded here if you'll
recall bumblebee I feel bad because
there must be something good about
Transformers because it's got a lot of
fans Joe star is one of them yeah like
that and I like the original movie for
being just a psychedelic freak Show the
classic it's got that same kind of like
core anime storytelling that is very
appealing like Transformer stories like
they start there's some new faux or
Megatron got some power up or whatever
and then they fight the Transformers the
Autobots lose but then they have to go
find a McGuffin a secret right power up
and that's unlocked it makes them more
powerful for the final showdown so you
could keep playing that that plot out
forever I just wish it looked better if
that's the case if it's just like a
Shonen anime of like I'm gonna get
strong and I'm gonna fight you no you're
not yeah let's fight like that's fine I
love that but it has to look cool
right I think that's what that's what we
always miss is I well I just I feel like
we've now gotten with there was a
Transformers movie that sort of nailed
the storytelling there was there have
been Michael Bay sometimes almost got to
where the action was okay if we could
just get all these disparate elements
together in one movie it could work we
just added another toy that's never had
a good movie made about it how about
that well let's continue and see where
that goes yeah
have turned him into the racist Uncle
the other Autobots tolerated family
gatherings you brought a human here I
should have known better than to rely on
humans
a motorcycle armed with NSA government
surveillance Powers private
it's fun and not at all like a cop
bumblebee who is also there
they're joined by the maximals the kind
of tool you get when you ask Mom for
Dinobots but she says you already have
Dinobots at home Joy these transforming
Robo animals that the movie forgets can
translate
talk about forgets and they did this
again with the Dinosaurs in
the other the other transfers movie that
didn't have enough dinosaurs perfect
thank you because age of Extinction I
will say that like that was seemingly
the selling point of this movie Rise of
the Beast you're gonna you're gonna go
into the beast land you're gonna have a
beast War it's bizarre I can tell you
Optimus primal I could tell you bird
lady air razor I don't think any of the
other Beast Bots had a single line maybe
there's there's a there's a Jaguar guy
and a rhino guy but they don't really
get anything to do and so we meet the
maximals at the very very first there's
a there's an open cold open where we
meet the maximals and we watch them get
their ass kicked by Peter Dinklage uh
like three minute long scene barely even
an action scene they then disappear from
the film for an hour for a full hour
where we don't see a single maximal or
and find out anything going on with them
they should open Peru yeah then they're
only and then they're only in the very
last climactic action scene and we only
see them transform like they turn in
from their Beast form no they have
another action scene where they get
smoked again by Scourge right where they
the very last action scene in the movie
is the first and only time we see them
actually turned into robots from Beasts
which is dollars max out yeah the whole
selling point like why if this is the
the Beast movie they should be all over
this this thing right like why are they
holding back now there's no reason to
hold back uh
uh it's worse yeah begun the Beast it is
it is the same thing as age of
Extinction where it's like no no
Grimlock should be the star of this
movie what are you doing it's Optimus
versus Optimus primal like don't don't
muddy the waters with anything else like
there's there's animal Transformers they
have to fight the truck I it seems
obvious that you would just the maximals
would be the stars of this movie because
that's the big thing you're introducing
yeah I don't I don't get why you would
like dribble them in at the end because
it's like it's like oh but next time
we're gonna blow the doors off and it's
like there's not even gonna be a next
time now because you blew it yeah
gotta reboot again did you learn nothing
from the rise you're gonna have to
reboot again they are rebooting again
with um Hemsworth there's an animated
right they're doing the animated one
yeah we'll see we'll see all right keep
going
device
but don't worry they'll get more to do
in the sequel what do you mean if this
even gets a sequel what do you mean if
movies even exist two years from now
we're kick-starting the hasbrovers bro
we're in the middle of an ongoing war
and we'd love to have you join the fight
you and your whole team see Studio
wouldn't promise a franchise that they
end up failing on it'll be total chaos
going back through the uh through those
options that was particularly tickled by
the King Arthur one where they're like
it's a round table
that's good and then there's another
wait for it yeah the latest of the
Endless Robin Hood attempts um yeah that
also ended with a good one where they
look over at a tree line and they go the
forest
sure would yes
you're not you're not getting another
one guys it's never happening the
original Mario movie has a good one
where the princesses show up dressed
like Rambo
um yeah with like flame like aliens uh
level flamethrower guns yeah like we
have to go back I mean the greatest of
all time Masters of the Universe yeah
Skeletor I'll be back
well never say never but frankly Angela
bring him back out 90 year old uh cancer
and we'll see how they'll see how the
strike goes with AI we might have
Franklin tour forever he's actually in
the flesh
um all right keep going
if you peek really closely at one of the
orbs if you zoom in on an orb you can
see Dolph Lundgren and Frank langella
you can see them both he's like what are
we doing here this is I don't even are
we DC is this I thought we were there's
a clue for next week all right keep
going
friends corpse and a handgun made out of
his friends just don't ask what part of
my body it came from
Cronenberg is for a kids movie work
friends you've been inside me that's
just engine oil huh what is this crash
it's a reshaping of the human body but
we got that in there yeah once Noah gets
his fresh new Corp suit watch a human
finally join the fight alongside the
Transformers rather than limply firing
an AR-15 at a Decepticon Tyree style
save yourself
even though he still needs a lot of help
yeah why can't I even bring humans along
at all humans can't fight a metal
gorilla humans can't even find a normal
gorilla I mean I could but that's not a
discussion you're ready to have so like
they they go to all this trouble they
spend half the movie setting up Noah
getting a suit made out of his friend
that now he can fight on the level of a
transformer he a human gets to save
Optimus Prime at the end but then he he
can't actually do it and he misses him
and you need the gorilla to come what's
the point of that it's weird because the
theme of the film is like Noah you gotta
you gotta work together you're too much
you're trying to do it all on your own
shoulders humans and Autobots have been
they've been trying to save themselves
but they should be working together
against their common phone and the way
he resolves that and like uh resolves
that dramatic tension is by wearing the
corpse of his dead friend so he can be
strong enough to do it by himself still
not strong
it just under my like for no real I
guess dramatic tension in that moment if
you think Optimus Prime is gonna die and
then Ron Perlman saves him I don't know
that boy doesn't work like it would have
been a lot more satisfying emotionally
if Anthony Ramos just gets to save him I
mean it wouldn't be emotionally
satisfying because it's a bad movie but
and he and operators probably have two
words together human yeah optimism
really like they I get the the arc is he
realizes he has an arc which is it's
okay to work but uh they lay it on a
little thick to where he's like oh he's
like he he really he feels like like
Richie in the bear it's like is this
okay I don't keep going he should say
stuff like that
the promotional trip down to beautiful
Peru enjoy the lovely scenery and
Charming local color get to know the
people and their ancient culture while
exploring the fascinating Incan Villages
and ruins that dot the entire landscape
of the country's Serene sacred Valley
ah Brew it's beautiful oh and watch
Robots pull each other's spines out with
her bare hands
I did not see this
oh
really
like the fact that they're robots
that's my job
brutal give me your face story
in the fights Optimus and the black
Messiah already dating Penelope Pitstop
Prime day Kong Perlman I drink and I
explode things like And subscribe this
is what Peak Performance looks like
ah the French campaign and there is more
to them than meets the eye
we fought a zoo
it's very good
I think pause we kind of used that
before with um one of the dumb uh Harry
Potter movies where he brought a zoo but
I feel like yeah that the fan one of
those fantastic we all love referencing
one of those great movie titles still
can't believe they bought that freaking
Zoo what do you think happened at the
zoo after they bought it I guess I have
to watch the film they they run it never
did then it's there then it's their Zoo
Matt Damon Matt Damon I just read that
Matt Damon turned down Avatar and he
would have gotten profit participation
in that movie if he had signed on Wow to
do We Bought a Zoo to do I mean the
dates maybe line up instead he could
have bought a zoo that's all I'm saying
I mean that is why it's Cameron Crow did
we find who I get I get why you do like
oh you know this one guy buys a zoo that
sounds charging all right all right
Jerry Maguire might not have sounded
like much on the page
other zoo movie
I'll get back to you on the zoo Kevin
James yes no different one but it was
like a Prestige I think Robert Pattinson
was worked in his own it's Water for
Elephants yes yeah the universe yeah a
cinematics universe yeah we're gonna do
that next week
um sorry Dumbo Dumbo in there keep going
okay what are the rules
grows before hoes okay that phrase
didn't gain popularity until the
mid-2000s though you could argue that
the first use of the phrase was in
common sense a song in my own world in
1994 the senior this film takes place
however that album didn't release until
October and in this scene you can
clearly see the calendar is set to June
1994. and this is why nobody wants to
talk to me at parties I hope someone got
fired for that blender uh okay let's do
questions first because I'm truly about
to lose power on this old uh I would
like to say uh common does not get
credit for coining bros before hoes
congratulations to come what a what a
contribution that's huge but I'll I'll
bet it was like in The Ether of you know
the 90s before it showed up in that song
probably were the first you know scribe
to say hmm I feel like maybe what rhymes
with Bros common sense I'm a rap artist
what could I rhyme with bro hmm
[Laughter]
um okay uh let's see so uh MJ pretzer
asks if you could cross this franchise
or GI Joe with a completely nonsensical
pairing what would you pick or a good
one um I say Friday the 13th what would
you pair Transformers with everyone says
Fast and Furious I mean yeah like it
just it does seem like Fast and the
Furious is like the most the most
obvious one I I would also say though I
think that you could do Expendables like
I think that like Expendables because
Expendables is is so violent as well
like it almost makes sense like the
Transformers and The Expendables fight
in a similar way where it's just like
I'm going to obliterate you okay yeah
yeah I think you've got me uh relating
it to anime I think like if it's a
Gundam thing like let's get just a legit
Mech versus Transformer oh yeah they go
to Japan and they have to fight just
robots just like the robots I'm into
that yeah uh Adam Halbert thoughts on
the animated movie coming up with
Hemsworth voicing Optimus I feel we are
overdue for a no humans movie by now
sure yeah I mean that's the way to go I
think like let's let's give the people
what they want but if they're not humans
then why would they ever turn into a
truck and or Boombox correct or a
helicopter at some point them coming to
Earth is kind of crucial because
otherwise the transforming into Earth
objects doesn't really make sense yeah
I'm not even saying no humans I just
feel like we tend to get bogged down in
human world whereas like I think the
original like the 80s animated movie is
like that's the level of humans like
they're humans around but they don't
they're not the center right
um yeah I think they're going fishing
from what I understand they're going
full like Space Opera with this yes it's
different it's it's like Fall of
Cybertron so it's in space we'll check
it out uh let's see benzai 10 Haley you
feel Fair people if you have any updates
about the SAG after strike then please
let us know as far as I know there are
no I mean the rock made a huge donation
which is great the people's champ thank
you rock that's that's awesome uh no
there's no updates because the the
they're not negotiating is not meeting
they they're the like what we're hearing
the rumors the word on the street I have
no official backing on this but like
it's like Netflix especially in the
streamers they don't mind dragging this
out they're willing to give it until
towards the end of the year if you think
about it
for the for the studios for like
Paramount Disney for those companies
Sony they want to end the strike quickly
they've got movies they want to bring
out into theaters they need to Pat there
and promote streaming services they want
to get acting promotion back exactly but
for like Netflix and Amazon and apple
first of all hugely Deep Pockets they
can just wait and they're saving money
right now they can make money they can
make shows in Korea and and reality
Canada and reality shows and meanwhile
all the money that they would be paying
actors and show Runners to make new
content they just get to save it Wall
Street kind of likes that so they're not
in the same hustle as like Disney like
Disney would love to resolve this
tomorrow because they've got movies and
content they want to bring out they
don't have other businesses to fall back
on well you know Parks cruises right but
not in the way like apple like apples
like Amazon this is a rounding error for
Apple yeah like they're not even that's
not even their primary thing that they
do and Netflix they've got a pipeline of
content they can sit on what they've
already got for a year but then I
imagine there's places like peacock I
guess NBC right whatever uh who are
probably sweating bullets beat because
like they can't afford to pay anymore
because they're already one and fire
they already threw away the cable Market
at ad rates are drying up nobody's
advertising right now so yeah those
companies are in a huge pinch it's just
they're in this organization with
Netflix that's fine to drag its feet so
that's what what we're hearing is that
the streamers are the ones that are
really holding everything up and the
studios are in a much more into
everything delicate position streaming
has ruined truly everything streaming
kind of through we had this great
business model cable and carriage deals
and everything kind of was paid for way
to go Flixster and it was this 50 60
year old business model that was messy
but worked and then we threw all of that
away and now streaming is we're on our
we want our content yeah yeah you want
it now but streaming is just like
fundamentally broken so Benjamin Brown
that's right speaking of bay Farmers
have you ever considered doing a trailer
for every Michael Bay movie yes and we
should um I don't want to rewatch can we
do every Michael Bay movie minus
Transformers or maybe lion will launch
all the time
that's fine great I I like Michael Bay
movies uh no me too I just did that I'm
done with this franchise I sort of
celebrate the whole catalog yeah
um let's see
Bad Boys 2 just had an anniversary I
think it's just turned 10. bad boys this
is a good this is a good one uh James
Bond with Hollywood shutting down what
movie getting an honest trailer would be
a cry for help if you have to do it
what's our like blink twice if you're
being held hostage um on his trailer
we've sort of done this yeah right next
week I feel like is is as close as we
can I'm gonna do all my favorite movies
that I've like loved to go back to so it
would just have to God I don't even know
I don't know I mean talk to us six
months from now when movies stop coming
out
um yeah we'll we'll let you know then
we'll be sending Garden State I feel
like that would be no I want to rip into
that rip that a new one a new giant hole
to scream into good buddy
um all right so uh let's end with this
um
uh Reynard City update Channel what
recent director would be a good
Transformer voice uh
uh Nikolai says uh oh like well who
should we hand it over to no not well
like who would voice Transformer no what
director I'm I'm choosing to interpret
it as what director should get the
Reigns of this Frame oh okay because I
was thinking like Orson Welles voices
unicorn
um hmm what director should do a
Transformer I'm debating do we give a
serious answer or do we give a bit of a
fun I mean I'm tempted to say because
she just nailed a toy adaptation credit
card what would Gerwig do with the
Transformers what would what that that's
I think Gerwig bombas is my you're going
to turn her into the toy director I want
her to be the she we put her on on in
charge of all the toy at it she'll do
Stretch Armstrong Hot Wheels she could
take over Hot Wheels from JJ Abrams
um I would do uh whoever made extraction
two I think you need a really good
action director Sam Hargrove Hargrave
Hargrave Sam Hargrave you're up um yeah
we're attracted to rules yeah whoever
can do uh because I figured the John
Wick people have enough on their plans
to helski's very but extraction two was
so good when he takes that when he takes
that enormous minigun that looks like
it's too big for a human he's a human
Transformer and it's Hemsworth who's
already in the Transformers franchise
walks he's on like a boat train he's on
a train yeah and he picks up this mini
guy but it is the size of him it looks
like it weighs two tons yeah uh and he
just walks out of it into an open air
part of the trade and uses it to shoot
down a helicopter helicopters which is
casually so casually this is what uh
it's like a Halo show yeah it's like
Schwarzenegger mid 80s like Peak shorts
today my favorite part is when he gets
hit with a Molotov cocktail and he
blocks it with his arm he has arms on
fire so now he just has a firearm yeah
and he's just punching with his fire art
extraction too if you haven't it was
really good um all right so my my
computers we're done with this let's do
some deleted scenes if we got him
starring
10 gigabytes of Ramos meters Morales I
hate you drive just Warm Bodies beep
Davidson Bumble bead call in all cars
truck Turner Megabots there's more than
one way to lose a monkey house a killer
gorilla tinyon canister space Smithers
Mega Pawn Elena Scourge always slays his
debts wait a girl Transformer was not
even allowed yeah MTV flaps bird blocks
hot girl Crouching Tiger disguised robot
Captain Planet hungry hungry Cosmos
begun the Beast would have
everybody's got some key to hide except
for me and my monkey hell yeah age
together yawn
Fantastic Beasts and Where to fight them
wow a mostly empty Warehouse I can't
think of anything that might get a kid
more excited to see a movie than the
promise of a slightly Fuller Warehouse
well maybe if they have some random
guy's business card sold
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey Mirage buddy those are the kinds of
cars with people inside them you just
killed a bunch of cops yeah there you go
um so yeah I think just one last
reflection on the GI Joe of it all would
it have been better if they open up the
thing and The Rock and uh Channing Tatum
were standing there I'm trying to think
of who else was a GI Joe yes
I think Marlon Wayans is the way to go I
think that's who you need no I I it's
just it's like I don't I I don't know I
don't know GI Joe that well you needed
more than but like that's for sure but
like I feel like because here's what I
would say there there are ninjas who
don't show their face in GI Joe yeah why
not have them yeah there was a whole
movie about Snake Eyes why not have them
fighting you know where's Henry Golding
you don't even need to K you don't even
need Henry Golden to shop you don't need
to do casting because you could just
cover their face and then whoever you
cast is those characters they were there
yeah like the Shazam ending where
everyone's cut off at the neck yeah but
they're all in there
they also have like they have iconic
vehicles and weapon their toys to fill
that warehouse with iconography so at
least there's something that is like oh
my God they have this whole GI Joe verse
ready to go this is literally like kids
will be excited by the name Jojo and
Doug Stamper from House of Cards and
like look kids love Stamper yeah Michael
Kelly is a great character actor kids
love Stamper but like I it was so it was
nothing it was just like if you're gonna
try to get me excited about another
movie like actually try don't just like
hey maybe we'll make another one like
yeah I know if this does well you'll
make another one I know
we'll be there for the for the next one
uh there won't be a next one I don't I
really don't like I don't they would be
after how this one did I go back to the
drawing board I don't think they would
want to go now make a combined
Transformers GI Joe movie in this world
yeah although there we are creeping like
the X-Men slowly towards early 2000s
Nostalgia bait because we did the 80s
they did the 90s and now there's gonna
be like I just feel like waking up to
Limp Biscuit like oh no I think you do
full you do full reboot I I I just I I
think you give it a few years and then
you just restart Transformers at the
beginning I don't I don't think there's
any salvaging this probably for the best
um as will we uh look we gave you I
think I gave away what next week's
trailer was uh in the middle of the
commentary so if you're just skipping
ahead to just look at my cheat um we're
doing pregnant Sonics next week that's
next week's Son's Trailer listen
bringasonic's full of life there's
nothing there's nothing there's nothing
weird I'm curious about it
um
that's your clue for next week
we'll see you then right here on
Australians bye-bye
[Music]
foreign